lamartine vous êtes en train de regarder
d'essayer des vêtements ou bien de
regarder non non non je regarde parce
que là comme je travaille en
collaboration avec madame et talbot
c'est un peu normal tout des années je
viens me rends compte si les vêtements
sont au top parce que d'année en année
les vêtements ça change les touloulou
deviennent beaucoup plus belles beaucoup
plu à dieu et où sur un peu normal tant
que tant que capitaine du bateau
touloulou je suis obligé de me rendre
compte qu'au tour
tout est fait dans les meilleures
conditions
[Musique]
je ne veux
l'équipe
[Musique]
oui avec deux groupes à face à face l
homme bouazza billet le groupe sapotille
que depuis cinq six ans ils sont dans la
chaloupe avec moi et moi je suis très
satisfait d'autant plus qu'ils ont une
musique de qualité ils auraient perdra
spécialement pour le touloulou plus que
la musique est toujours étonné d'une
musique est bien bien bien bien spéciale
ces deux groupes qui sont en face à face
à face tous les 30 minutes donc à partir
de 21 heures jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
c'est de la musique s'en aille
cette année vous avez choisi de
décentraliser vous avez laissé saint
joseph est pas que cette année l'année
dernière aussi
bon on avait un petit souci avec le
domaine de olivier bloch qui ça qu'ils
s'apprêtaient très bien à cette
manifestation mais pour un petit manque
de parkings puisque effectivement le
parquet nous un peu juste on a décidé de
le faire aux membres ça nous permet
d'avoir beaucoup plus de place beauvau
la salle est le plus petit mais plus
petit devient plus convivial aussi et
cette année on renouvelle cette
expérience là est encore aux mangues
il y aura la remise de diplômes mais
comme d'habitude mais comme d'habitude
mais il ne peut pas avoir mais comment
qu'on peut dire que moi j'étais au bal
de toulouse et j'ai très bien passé et
que je n'ai pas aussi maudite sommes
donc chaque poule ou parce que je les
observe
les gens qui menacent pas mal non jamais
de du club donc c'est moi je suis le
recteur de l'académie de toulouse de la
montée n'est donc le diplôme est
obligatoire pour les gens qui savent
piqué